after two years of covered restrictions
today marks a big step so how solid is
the ground beneath us a big part of the
government's confidence is the falling
numbers of hospitalizations and deaths
way down on where they were in previous
waves but deaths with kovid still
significant averaging around 140 deaths
a day
so does ending the legal requirement to
self-isolate change that trajectory well
one thing plan b taught us is it depends
on people's behavior in some aspects of
life we're back at pre-pandemic levels
of behavior look at essential shopping
here in blue back up to the dotted line
where it was before the pandemic but
people on public transport still well
below normal levels here in red we know
workplaces are not at usual capacity so
lots of room for mixing to increase and
with it infections
arguably more significant is ending free
testing why is that important well look
here at cases from the government
dashboard seemingly falling rapidly but
look now at how many tests we're doing
much of that falling case numbers is
because we're not testing as much after
ending asymptomatic and travel testing
last month
a good thing then that we're keeping the
ons infection survey which gives a far
truer picture it shows cases are not
falling at the speed there on the
dashboard in fact around 1 in 20 people
currently have covered in england a
stubbornly high number
given that what do today's changes mean
for those who've been advising
government throughout the pandemic
personally i don't see this as a cliff
edge moment i see this as a as part of a
necessary progression
of how do you live with a new pathogen
at some point you need to get science
you need to get industry and business
and the population
back up to running at full steam i think
what we've got to hope
is that
good behavior good leadership leads to
sensible
reactions from our population
the insurance policy against a
resurgence in infections and the threat
of new variants of course is vaccines 98
of the population have antibodies in
england now and it's similar in other
nations largely due to vaccination the
vaccines of course mean far fewer people
of dying of covid and that means
attention should naturally shift of
course to those at risk of dying from
something else
number of people waiting for treatment
on the nhs has been growing for 18
months
and has now topped off at over 6 million
people
today the government has taken another
calculated risk with covid hoping we
follow guidance rather than rules
freeing up resources for the other risks
we face